to his supporters he is tommy robinson
citizen journalist
to the judges at the old bailey he's
stephen yaxley lennon and they've
already found him to be in contempt of
court
this was him being arrested outside
leeds crown court last year
he was broadcasting live on social media
about a sex abuse case
but a judge had banned reporting because
there were multiple related trials
extending over several months
there were no reporting restrictions on
his case today though so as he arrived
alongside the commentator katie hopkins
i could interview him i'm telling you i
am being sent to jail for doing what
you've just done
i'm not saying what you've done is wrong
i'm saying that if you experience the
reporting restrictions on this case i
don't know this is political persecution
how can i be sent to prison for asking a
pedophile how he feels about his
sentence that's all i asked
you want to talk about yourself there's
earlier this week he told an american
internet channel
that he wanted donald trump to grant him
asylum in the u.s
i beg donald trump i beg the american
government just look
at my case if you look at my case you
will see the wrongdoings did i need
evacuation out of this country
why are you asking for asylum well i'm
asking for it because i'm about because
[Music]
that original sentence was overturned on
appeal but the attorney general ordered
a re-trial
by the time he took his place in the
courtroom he changed his t-shirt for one
without slogans supporters clogged the
street as they waited for more than an
hour
to find out what his punishment would be
there were angry scuffles
when news filtered out that he'd been
sentenced to nine months imprisonment
given the time he spent in jail last
year tommy robinson is likely to be
freed
within around 10 weeks but in passing
sentence dame victoria sharp said that
nothing less than a custodial penalty
would properly reflect the gravity of
the conduct we have identified
she said the court is also determined to
demonstrate its determination
to uphold the rule of law as robinson
was being taken to prison
his supporters headed for westminster to
continue the protest
several of them were arrested inwards
sky news
at the old baylor